[موسيقى]
مساء الخير لا يمكن للكوارث الطبيعيه اللي
بحجم زلزال يوم الاثنين 6 فبراير اللي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا ان تقتصر اثاره على الخسائر
البشريه والاقتصاديه لهذه الكوارث الكبيره
يكون لها عاده اثار سياسيه بعيده المدى
يعني تتغير الاولويات تسقط حكومات تصعد
حكومات تتغير السياسات الخارجيه للدول اذا
اردنا مثال لتوضيح الفكره تاثير الكوارث
الطبيعيه على السياسات الداخليه والخارجيه
لسنا في حاجه لان نذهب بعيدا تركيا بتقدم
لنا مثال واضح وفي التاريخ الحديث مكانا
متصورا ابدا من حوالي 25 سنه
كلها احزاب تحسب على التيار الكمالي
الاتاتركي نسبه لمؤسس الدوله التركيه
الحديثه مصطفى كمال اتاتورك اللي ما كانش
ابدا ابدا يعني
ممكن تتسامح او تتشجع لوجود حزب اسلامي
بدا الناس يرحبوا بفكره التغيير وعليه كان
الحزب العداله والتنميه في طريقه الى
الصعود قدم نفسه باعتباره انه حزب اكثر
كفاءه وقدره على التعامل مع احتياجات
الناس ممهد الطريق لصعوده للسلطه بعد ثلاث
سنوات تحديدا في الفين واثنين
الان يمكن ان يحدث تغيير جديد هذا التغيير
الجديد قد يعضد بقاء حزب العداله والتنميه
اللي بقاله حوالي عشرين سنه في السلطه وقد
يطيح به كما اطاح بحكومات سبقته عام
1999 عشان نعرف ايه التغيرات اللي يمكن ان
تحدث في تركيا وفي سوريا اللي هم البلدين
اللي ضرب بشكل رئيسي من هذا الزلزال لازم
نعرف كانت ما هي الاوضاع قبل سته فبراير
قبل هذا الزلزال قبل الساعات الاولى من
يوم 6 فبراير الماضي كان السلطه كان الحزب
المسيطر ولمده 20 سنه طبعا في تركيا هو
الحزب العداله والتنميه وزعيمه رجب طيب
اردوغان ما كان الشغل الشاغل لاردوغان
وحزبه في الشهور الاخيره في العام الاخير
الفوز في الانتخابات ولا صوت يعلو على
الفوز في الانتخابات علشان يفوز في
الانتخابات اتخذ مجموعه كبيره من السياسات
الداخليه ومجموعه كبيره من السياسات
الخارجيه سياسات الداخليه ليس شاننا احنا
مش قناه تركيا ولكن كان هدف السياسات
الداخليه لمن يتابع تركيا باعتبارها دوله
كبيره ومؤثره في المنطقه هيلاحظ انه الحزب
الحكومه الرئيس اتخذ مجموعه من السياسات
كان هدفها
تخفيف من الازمه اقتصاديه على واثرها على
الناس حتى وان كان على حساب الاقتصاد على
المدى البعيد يعني مثلا زي ما اتكلمنا في
حلقات سابقه اصر اصرارا كبيرا جدا على خفض
فوائد البنوك
رغم ان هذا يتعارض مع منطق الاقتصاد املا
في ان الناس تاخد قرود وتستدين وتشعر
بالارتياح حتى وان اضر ذلك الاقتصاد
التركي مستقبلا اصر على رفع الرواتب ورفع
المعاشات حتى وان ضعفت تضخم الذي يعاني
منه الاتراك مجموعه كبيره من السياسات لكن
ما يعنينا منها هنا السياسه الخارجيه
باعتبارنا قناه مهتمه بالعلاقات الدوليه
بدا اردوغان حتى يفوز في الانتخابات يصلح
او ينقلب على سياساته الخارجيه اللي
اتبعها لسنوات مضت وقدت الى توتر علاقاته
بكثير من الدول هذا التوتر انعكس سلبا على
الاقتصاد التركي لان هذه الدول انصرفت عن
التعاون مع تركيا ولانه يرغب في الفوز في
الانتخابات ولن يفوز في الانتخابات الا
بانعاش الاقتصاد التركي ولن ينتعش
الاقتصاد التركي الا بانه يعود مره اخرى
للتعاون
مع كل حلفائه الاقليميين والدوليين فراينا
كيف انه يعني
غير من موقفه تماما مع اسرائيل وزار وزير
خارجيته اسرائيل وزارته اسرائيل ذهب الى
دول الخليج يعني الغى كل الكلام الخشن
اللي كان بيقولوا عن زعماء هذه الدول صافح
الرئيس المصري
وتبادلوا المكالمات لاحقا كل شيء تقريبا
تغير في السياسه الخارجيه التركيه وكان
اخر محطه لهذا التغير هو اصراره على
المصالحه مع سوريا
ومقابله الاسد وهي التغير الذي اثار ضجه
في الاسابيع والشهور القليله الماضيه ضجه
في تركيا ضجه بين
السوريين اللي موجودين في المناطق اللي
بتسيطر عليها تركيا في سوريا
والسوريين المقيمين في تركيا
وكانت الحسبه كالاتي برضو مره اخرى السبب
انتخابي بحت اردوغان يريد المصالحه مع
سوريا فقط وبسكل رئيسي حتى يفوز في
الانتخابات كيف يمكن ان تكون المصالحه
عامل اساسي لفوزه في الانتخابات سببين
وتعرضنا لهم في حلقه سابقه لكن سوف يعني
اقولها باختصار ويمكنكم ان تعودوا للحلقه
كامله التي سوف اضع لكم رابطها وكانت
بعنوان لماذا يلحق اردوغان على لقاء الاسد
لمكه المساله باختصار انه كان كانت
الحسابات التركيه قبل يوم 6 فبراير الماضي
انه المصالحه مع الدكتور بشار الاسد يمكن
ان تحقق هدفين اساسيين او تساعد اردوغان
في امرين اساسيين
يعززه من فرصه في الانتخابات الاول
وان هذه المصالحه ان تمت يمكن ان تساعد
اردوغان في اعاده اكبر عدد ممكن من
اللاجئين الموجودين اللاجئين السوريين
الموجودين على الاراضي التركيه اذكركم مره
ثانيه وثالثه ورابعه انه مع يعني
الازمه الاقتصاديه مع اشتعال الازمه
الاقتصاديه والضغوط الاقتصاديه على
الاتراك كان طبيعي زي اي شعب انه بيبدا
يلقي باللائمه على اللاجئين لماذا
تزاحموننا على فرص العمل نحن نعاني
فاذهبوا الى بلدكم وزي ما قلت لحضراتكم
قبل كده انه اللاجئين في تركيا لا يقتصر
على السوريين رئيس اردوغان اللي على مدى
سنوات اتبع سياسه الابواب المفتوحه
للاجئين لما كان عنده طموح ان تلعب بلده
دورا كبيرا كقوه كبيره اقليميه ودوليه فتح
ابوابه للاجئين من دول مختلفه
وبلغ عدد اللاجئين وفقا للارقام الحكوميه
حوالي 8 مليون لاجئ
نصفهم تقريبا سوريين وبالتالي هو المعارضه
على مدار شهور بتضغط بكارت اللاجئين
وبيقولوا له هذا ما كانت يداك ان وصلنا
الى السلطه سوف نعيد هؤلاء اللاجئين الى
سوريا وسوف نتصالح مع النظام السوري
لاسباب منها اعاده اللاجئين وتخفيف حده
الازمه الاقتصاديه على الاتراك كان اول
هدف من المصالحه مع رئيس بشار الاسد هو ان
يسحب هذا الكارت من المعارضه سوف اعيد
اللاجئين وبالتالي ليس لديكم ما يمكن ان
تقدموه للاطراك اكثر مني الامر الثاني هو
التعاون مع بشار الاسد على مواجهه
الجماعات الكرديه المسلحه وتحديدا قست
اللي هي بترقص او اللي هي صاحبه الابرهاند
في الاداره الذاتيه في مناطق شمال شرق
سوريا
اذا تعاون معهم هو طبعا تعاون معهم لان هو
فشل في ان هو يتخلص منها هؤلاء الجماعات
المسلحه وجماعات قصد بالعمليات العسكريه
المتلاحقه ودي قصه شرحناها لا اريد ان
اعود اليها مره اخرى بالتفصيل فشل في
التخلص من هؤلاء على حدوده بالقوه
العسكريه فقرر وطبعا بسبب الاعتراضات
الامريكيه والروسيه والايرانيه من انه
يقوم بعمليه عسكريه رابعه ضدهم وخامسه في
سوريا بصفه عامه
وبالتالي فكر بما اننا عجزت عن ان اقوم
ذلك بالقوه العسكريه لماذا لا اقوم به
بالتعاون مع بشار الاسد لدينا مصلحه
مشتركه في الضغط على هذه الجامعات اللي
عندها طموحات انفصاليه داخل سوريا
واذا هو نجح في اقناع بشار الاسد في انه
يتعاون معه في الضغط على هذه الجامعات
بحيث يبعدها ويقلل نفوذها في شمال سوريا
هيحقق مارب كثيره جدا اول هذه المقارب
المشمال سوريا سوف يخلو للسيد اردوغان
يمكن ان يعيد فيه اكبر عدد ممكن من
اللاجئين
واذا اعاد اللاجئين يبقى تخفف من عبقهم
ويتخفف من عبقهم
محققا هدفا اخر انه تخلص من الخطر الكردي
ويصور نفسه او سوف يعني يتم تصويره في
الداخل التركي باعتباره انه
مش بس استجاب لهواجسهم الاقتصاديه ولكن ده
كمان حمى مصالحهم الامنيه بابعاد الجماعات
الكرديه اللي ممكن تشكل خطر على الامن
القومي التركي
ويقوم بتسكين عدد كبير من اللاجئين
السوريين في شمال سوريا حتى وان لم يكونوا
قد انتموا الى هذه المنطقه من قبل
ويحقق هدف ثالث قديم له ولكثير من الساسه
الاتراك هو انه احتل شمال سوريا عمليا
بتمويل اوروبي الاوروبيين كان في مخطط
اردوغان هيموله المدن اللي هيقيم فيها
اللاجئين وبمباركه دوليه يعني حاجه عظيمه
جدا انما كان دايما الكلام اللي مطروح على
مدار شهور هو امكانيه تحقيق هذه الرؤيه
اللي تبدو عظيمه جدا له بحيث انه لا يمكن
ان تتحقق على العموم
كانت هذه الحسابات وكانت هذه هي الدوافع
للقائه ورغبته في لقاء بشار الاسد ومره
تاني انا كان في تقديري ان كل هذه
الطموحات يصعب ان تتحقق على هذا النحو لكن
حتى لو لم تتحقق كان اهم شيء وراءها سوف
يتحقق بالنسبه لاردوغان وهي ان يسحب ورقه
التصالح مع بشار الاسد ويقول لناخبيه انا
اسعى بجديه ولو كان نجح في اقناع بشار
الاسد بضغط من الروس اللي لهم مصلحه في
انه اردوغان ينجح في الفتره المقبله كان
ذلك يكفي جدا التقاط صوره تعني انني اسير
في المسار الذي تريدونه ثم ينجح في
الانتخابات ووقتها لكل حادثه حديث كانت
هذه الحسابات قبل يوم 6 فبراير الماضي جاء
الزلزال فتغيرها كل شيء ايه اللي تغير
الزلزال العميق جدا اللي حصل واللي ادى
الى
وفاه واستشهاد الاف كثيره جدا وعشرات
الالاف من الجرحى وتشريد الملايين على
الجانبين غير الاولويات هي كان ايه الهدف
الاساسي كانت الانتخابات الان
الانتخابات الاساس فيها او هيكون العامل
الاساس فيها هو طريقه مواجهه هذه اثار هذه
النكبه العظيمه الناخب سوف يعطي صوته في
تركيا
للرئيس وللحزب ان استطاع ان يدير ازمه او
كارثه الزلزال بكفاءه وسوف يصوت ضده ان
فشل في اداره اثار الزلزال كل شيء بدايه
من يوم سته ولشهور مقبله هيتعلق
بالزلزال واثاره المعركه الانتخابيه بدات
محل لحظات الاولى لاندلاع الزلزال واللي
يتابع تصريحات الحزب الرئيس النائب من
اللحظات الاولى هو
يصور نفسه باعتباره انه يدير ازمه بشكل
كفء جدا يقدم الاعذار لاي تقصير ربما لمسه
الناس يهاجم المعارضه المعارضه تهاجمه
وتسلط الضوء على عدم كفاءته وفشله
وطبعا هو لا يستطيع ان ينجو بسهوله من كل
انتقادات المعارضه لانه هو مش في السلطه
من اربع سنين ولا من ثمان سنين ده بقى له
20 سنه فكل البنيه التحتيه التي انهارت كل
المشاريع كلها من صنع يديه على العموم
المساله انتخابيه بعد
المتوقع كالتالي واحد انه اول تاثير لهذه
الكارثه انه الانتخابات اللي هي المحرك
الرئيسي لكل تصرفات الحزب والرئيس على
مدار شهور قد تتاجل ليه تتاجل لان البنيه
التحتيه قد لا تكون مناسبه لاجراء
الانتخابات هو هو بالفعل اعلن الرئيس
اردوغان اعلن حاله الطوارئ في عشر مدن او
ولايات الاكثر تاثرا بالانتخابات
ربما يتم مدها وهو هيمد هو هي هو هياجل
الانتخابات او يعقدها وفقا لاعتبارين
الاعتبار الاول صادق جدا هل
قدر بعد عشر ثلاث شهور لان الانتخابات
هتعقد بدايه من 14 مايو وهتستمر الى منتصف
يونيو انتخابات برلمانيه ورئاسيه هل
المناخ والبيئه جاهزه لاجراء حياه
انتخابيه او الاج دوره انتخابيه طبيعيه
ولا لا الامر الثاني الحزب الحاكم هو اللي
هياخد القرار وفي الحاله دي هياخدوا وفقا
لمصالحه اذا وجد ان الراي العام
سعيد بادائه سوف يعقد الانتخابات فورا اذا
وجد هناك سخطا على طريقه ادارته للزلزال
سوف يؤجل الانتخابات تحت اي ذريعه من
الذرائع اضف الى ذلك انه الزلزال مثل
عمليه الانقلاب او الانقلاب الفاشل في
يوليو 2016 هيكون فرصه للرئيس وللحزب ان
يتخلصوا من خصومهم بالمساله بدات بدري جدا
يعني الصحف التركيه بتتحدث عن انه النيابه
العامه تحقق مع صحفيين بتهمه اثاره اخبار
كاذبه تثير القلق العام وتكدر السلم
اخبار كاذبه بشان تعامل السلطه مع اداره
ملف الزلزال او قضيه الزلزال من المنتظر
انه هذا سوف يتصاعد كما سوف تتصاعد معه
انتقادات المعارضه اللي بعضها على حق
وبعضها يكون على باطل
ده اولا
ثانيا هيكون هيكون من غير المنطقي ابدا
انه السيد اردوغان يفكر في حاجتين اي
عمليه عسكريه في شمال سوريا اللي بيفكر
فيها من منتصف يوليو القادم ضد
الاكراد لم يعد مناسبا ان يفكر في هذه
العمليه على الارجح لن يقوم بها لشهور لا
لا يوجد لديه حافز لا انتخابي مع تاجل
الانتخابات مع او مع قدرته على تاجيل
الانتخابات لانه اذا لم يؤجلها يبقى
معناها ان هو يعني الراي العام معه فهو
ليس في حاجه
لزياده شعبيته بعمليه عسكريه خارجيه
ولا القدره الجيش مشغول بقضايا اخرى منها
المساعده في عمليات الانقاذ
يعني التعامل مع الزلزال وبالتالي سوف
تتاجل هذه العمليه العسكريه على الارجح
على الارجح لانه التغيرات يعني كل يوم
بيحمل الينا جديد انا بتكلم في اللحظه
اللي احنا فيها ليس من المنطقي انه الرئيس
اردوغان المنشغل في الزلزال يمكن ان يفكر
في عمليه عسكريه في شمال سوريا مع جماعات
قصد او غيرها
ثالث نتيجه منطقيه جدا
لعمليه الزلزال انه الرئيس ان الرئيس
اردوغان لن يكون لديه اي حافز الان
لمصالحه مع سوريا ولا للقاء بشار الاسد
يعني لانه الهدفين اللي كان عاوز اللي
دفعاه لمقابله بشار الاسد تقريبا يعني
تراجع في الاهميه ان لم ينتفى في الوقت
الحالي واحد انه
لم تعد فكره الكرد اللي موجودين على
الحدود قضيه راي عام ضاغطه في في الراي
العام التركي صعب ان تبقى قضيه انتخابيه
او اولويه لا للاتراك ولا وبالتالي ليس
للرئيس مش هتكون حاجه مؤثره
وهم كمان الكرد مشغولين بتدارك اثار
الزلزال اثنين
انه ليس معقولا ان يتصور اردوغان انه بشار
الاسد اللي هو كمان غارق في محاوله علاج
الزلزال انه قادر على مساعديه مساعدته لا
في مواجهه يعني
تحجيم نفود الكرد ولا في استقبال لاجئين
سوريين هو عنده مشكله في تلبيه احتياجات
السوريين اللي موجودين تحت حكمه بالفعل
فهل يعقل ان يضيف الى هؤلاء مئات الالاف
القادمين من تركيا يعني امر غير مقبول
وبالتالي تراجعت اهميه ملف المصالحه
بالكامل ايا كانت اهدافهم
الاهم من كل ده انه حين تعقد الانتخابات
وقتما تعقد اذا كانت في ما يونيو او حتى
في العاب المقبل سوف تظل طريقه اداره هذه
الكارثه عامل حاسم في تحديد نتائج
الانتخابات التركيه وفي تحديد مصير الحزب
الحاكم والرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
اما ان تجدد الثقه فيه لانه استطاع ان
يدير هذه الكارثه بكفاءه او ان تتيح به
كما اطاحت انتخابات كما اطاح زلزال 1999
بحكومات واحزاب تقليديه حكمت تركيا على
مدار 80 سنه منذ ان اسس
كمال مصطفى كمال اتاتورك تركيا الحديثه
وطبعا اذا ذهب السيد اردوغان سوف يقول
لذلك تاثير كبير جدا على كل دول الشرق
الاوسط وكل دول العالم
رجل له بسياسات له تاثير سواء لسياسات
الايجابيه والسلبيه تاثير كبير جدا هو زي
ما بيقولوا بالانجليزي هذا
لديه اصبع في مش عارف الترجمه الحرفيه
يعني لكن هو متدخل في كل شؤون دول المنطقه
اذا ذهب اردوغان سوف تتغير سياسات تركيا
كثيرا ومعها سوف تتغير علاقه التركيه بدول
المنطقه الاخرى
على صعيد الوضع في سوريا
الزلزال هيكون له تاثير كبير جدا ايضا على
كل القوى اللي موجوده لكن التنبؤ بها امر
بالغ الصعوبه ليه لانه احنا في تركيا ممكن
نتكلم على اصوات الناخبين كيف سوف تتاثر
ولماذا سوف تتاثر ونتيجه هذه الاصوات نقدر
نتنبا بالتغير في السلطه اللي موجود في
تركيا اما الانتخابات كلها فليست اليه
مؤثره يعني في تحديد مراكز القوه على
الاراضي السوريه لكن يظل رضا الناس وسختهم
مهم
راقبوا معركه المعركه على المساعدات وسوف
تدركون ذلك كل طرف من الاطراف الكثيره
التي تتحكم في مصائر السوريين ترغب في ان
تستحوذ على المساعدات الخارجيه وتديرها
بطريقتها بحيث
تعطي المساعدات للفئات الواقعه تحت نفوذها
فتعزز من شرعياتها وتمنعها عن السوريين
الواقعين تحت نفوذ القوه الاخرى فتقود من
شرعيه هذه القوى في مناطقها في سوريا ليس
لدينا سلطه واحده احنا الوضع في سوريا
عندنا اكثر من سلطه سلطه بشار الاسد نعم
عندنا سلطه الاداره الذاتيه بقياده الكرد
عندنا الشمال الغربي اللي مناطق سيطره
تركيا اللي فيها المعارضه السوريه
وجش ما يسمى بجس سوريا الحر بالاضافه الى
طبعا هيئه تحرير الشام القوه دي هي اللي
مسيطره دي مسيطره في الغرب دي مسيطره في
الشرق رئيس بشار يسيطر على باقي باقي
سوريا كل دول اوضعهم سوف تتغير وتتاثر
سلبا او ايجابا بقدرتهم على التعامل مع
اثار الزلزال لكن المؤكد انه
الاسد على الاقل جبهه تحرير الشام
المعارضه السوريه هتكون
في مازق كبير جدا لان هم كانوا بيعانوا
بشده عندهم اوضاع ماساويه لو كان الوقت
يسمح او ضاع ماساويه اقتصاد متداعي تماما
بنيه تحتيه متداعيه تماما مستويات معيشه
منخفضه تماما قبل الزلزال
وساءت جدا بعد الزلزال قدره هذه الاطراف
على اداره الازمه سوف يؤثر على بقائهم او
انفلات الاوضاع منهم
طبعا المساله لن تكون بهذه السهوله لان كل
هذه الاطراف موجوده ليس فقط بحكم رضا
الناس عليها ولكن لانهم
جزء من اجندات دول اخرى في المنطقه دول
كبيره روسيا ايران تركيا نفسها
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي المشهد في
سوريا سوف يكون مؤقتا لكن المؤكد ان كارثه
الزلزال سوف تكون عاملا مؤثرا جدا في
تغيير هذه الخريطه المعقده ومعها ان شاء
الله يكون لنا حلقات اخرى اشكركم دعائنا
بالرحمه
المتوفين شهداء الضحايا في من هذا الزلزال
على الجانبين
وتمنياتنا بالشفاء العاجل لكل الجرحى
اشكركم والى اللقاء